I just want to say something I realized
that we're all a salad spinner of
emotions right now you know and and and
you and feel what you gotta feel you
know feel what you gotta feel but the
way I see it is not now is not the time
to abandon America you guys you don't
want to go up and cry in some hockey
players mullet you guys hey here
and I love Canada but the most American
thing you can do is stay here be the
best you you can be make your community
better work love your family be good to
people something I want to tell you
something now that I'm having my an
Oprah moment now I want to tell you
something at the end of the day it is
people it is each and every one of you
it is you watching that make a country
great not some clown it sitting in the
White House
we are - we put too much power on that
person whoever that person was going to
be to make our lives better we have to
make our lives better so don't you guys
make America great you can make America
great